da-da-da-da-da-da-da
do the teeth hey hi hey hi Gilbert hey
Bobby
George what's up to you we got a white
man Bryce what's that white man breath
hey what's up we had a look at little
katsu there that was nice huh yeah we
got Gilbert in the house how your life
your life how you live good pretty good
yeah I guess yeah tomainia we got my
girlfriend kalila and listen guys this
very special podcast it's what probably
the one of the most special guests I've
ever had on the show we've had what
we've had a lot of good people
Stonestreet Jordan Peele Dave Navarro
was a good one a lot of cool but this
one is literally my favorite because um
just I would do a little back intro to
it I know they're literally I'm just I
want to be real okay there's not a human
being out there that I hated more I mean
you liked it when I watched like
Schindler's List right and I knew you
know they didn't show Hitler knit but I
probably hated this girl more than
Hitler I mean I used to pray to God if
he would take her off the face of the
planet
yeah but the funny thing about life very
mutual very mutual okay and what this is
the life these are life lessons and you
know pop pop it talks about life lessons
all the time all the time right you
never know the Lord surprises you with
many gifts it opens your heart if your
heart is open okay and we have now this
woman she's a comic very funny and
that's very difficult me to say but
she's very funny that was difficult to
say
but I said it and she is here she's very
funny
Eleanor Carrigan give her a round of
applause you may talk now Eleanor
amazing what an intro yeah that I I wish
you would bring me on stage like that
well what am i intros with you I don't
think I've ever followed you but I've
enjoyed you and they've been quite
nicely not only that she intrude me when
we had our 20-year war Yeah right yeah
was that long I imagine not liking
somebody for 20 years
[Music]